well as promised governor desantis joins
us right now to discuss why he did this
governor thanks so much for coming on
um so this is kind of a big move it
seems like why did you do it
well tucker you documented the
destruction that we've seen with these
soros prosecutors around the country
where they basically take it upon
themselves to determine which laws
should be followed and which laws should
not be followed and i can tell you in
florida's constitution
that constitution invests the veto power
in the governor not an individual
district attorney or a state attorney
where they can pick and choose and so i
asked my staff to review all state
attorneys in the state of florida i
wanted to see who was picking and
choosing and this is the guy that all
the line prosecutors all the law
enforcement said uh he thinks he can
pick and choose which laws and he
actually signed letters saying he
wouldn't force laws against
transgender surgeries for minors laws
protecting the right to life and then he
has all these policies in his agency
that are called presumptive
non-prosecution no the law is
presumptively enforced that's not
something that's acceptable right and so
we there today we made the decision did
the jarring thing about it though tucker
i had all these sheriffs from the area
there i had the former police chief in
tampa there's a lot of line prosecutors
in that office that are very happy uh
that this was done and so we took it
seriously we did a thorough review and
we pulled the trigger today
i mean it's so obviously
unconstitutional legislators make the
laws
judges decide whether they're consistent
with the constitution prosecutors have
no role in that they don't have the
legal right the constitutional right to
selectively enforce the law or am i
missing something
no you're right but here's the here's
what what soros is doing it's actually
smart on his part they can't get these
things enacted in a legislature where
you're just going to let criminal runs
run so what they do he will get involved
in these democrat primaries and the
democrat area he'll flush a million
dollars to get the radical to win the
primary then they usually win the
general because of the party affiliation
difference in the jurisdiction so then
you get them in there and what they do
is they want to change the criminal
justice system through non-enforcement
so it's a total enron around our
constitutional system the results
obviously have been destructive around
the country but it also really
undermines the idea that ours is
supposed to be a government of laws not
a government of individual men
even if i agreed with the results i
would hate it because it's a subversion
of democracy and i finally someone's
doing something more than wine thank you
governor desantis for coming outside i
appreciate it
thanks tucker
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight